there are so many influencers in the
carnivorous space that say you're not
healing it's because you haven't removed
the seasonings or the sweeteners or the
coffee you're not carnivoring harder you
should be adding organs and it's not
that simple I am a carnivore
nutritionist I believe in carnivore it's
healed me so much it's why I don't think
the fruit and honey stuff is ideal but
there is a point where carnivore only
works to a certain point and then you
have to look further I don't think it
means that you have to remove carnivore
as a healing mechanism but I want people
to get to a place of I choose to only
eat meat not I can only eat meat it's a
huge difference in healing